I have six grandchildren and that is
what I'm saying
and I'm sticking to it I am indeed a
grandmother of what I am a grandmother
of seventeen I was thinking the twist
for me mashed potatoes you just picked a
turn I used to be a closet dancer and so
I would move gonna pick up your right
leg whip and then Nene is you're gonna
put your opposite hand up and you're
gonna like go back like this yeah kind
of like in a snake-like motion yeah
exactly yeah whip whip in a man name on
this second exactly yeah there's no Nene
in between so it's whip when like you're
falling I don't fall why it's called
Nene so I could put it down I don't know
actually
and you can kind of like put your own
style on it you already know what it is
I'm good I knew with las it until I get
better at I think it's great
I think it's really funny I mean it's
like my dancing and that's really fun
I was thinking similar to slop the
Madison I love a lot more than these
steps I think I'm going to teach all the
grandchildren of working ah yeah it's
working I think that the word twerk King
comes from working your [ __ ]